by scott hicks
spies sports ventures equipment games dictates
language in colombia
o flavors is a discipline that mixes
soccer volleyball and gymnastics and also brings
an artistic discipline that is
music my name is frei julian maturana
valentierra i am a musician do not forget that
to synchronize the  sports with
music you have to have a little bit of rhythm
to understand this
strong sport teacher
[Music]
my name is leonardo rey my role in the
stock market ole being a trainer and player of this
discipline
here in bogotá there is a program
called 40 for 40 in  At the moment
the idea of this is to create values in the boys throug
sports [Music] I t
ink tha
we are going to bolt is a discipline
hose main objective is to give the bo
s a space so that the
can show all the imagination
they have i
bogotá st
[Music]
the city of bogotá is a somewhat
insecure city since I have also been the victim
of quite a few roses
that if in a context where there had been
many  cha violence
then
all this context led me to work
with the boys to tell them that there is
another way of living
my goal as a trainer is to give the
boys a space where they can
have fun and I think there is nothing more
cool than there are enough  things in a
sport that catch your attention everything
can be solved with sport
sport motivates one to be a better
person and it is a flavor that lends itself
to that
[Music]
[Applause]